was mit dem rasierapparat in wenigen
minuten erledigt ist wird hier zu einer
prozedur die mindestens 20 minuten ruhe
braucht die nassrasur mit dem messer sie
ist in deutschen großstädten wieder ein
service den immer mehr männer in
anspruch nehmen
manche verbinden sie mit einem neuen
haarschnitt andere kommen nur zum
rasieren oder zur waldpflege man kriegt
es auf jeden fall zu hause nicht so hin
und dann fühlt sich so als hätten sich
selber was gegönnt
und auch wenn man dann so drüber fährt
ich bitte mir das einfach das sind
unterschied der barbershop von david
fechner in münchen hier wird an eine
zeit angeknüpft
in der männer sich noch als gentleman
begriffen das spiegelt sich auch in der
einrichtung wider
sie stammt aus den dreißiger jahren des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
vor eineinhalb jahren hat das geschäft
seine türen geöffnet
david fechner rasiert täglich bis zu
zehn kunden in traditioneller manier
mir gefällt die zeit von damals mit den
alten möbeln und dazu kam einfach das im
fußbereich keiner mehr diese
dienstleistung für herren anbietet und
ich finde es eigentlich ganz schön
ich kann die haut besser spannen und ich
mache es einfach intensiver als man zu
hause machen würde
jetzt nimmt sich ein bisschen mehr zeit
also gerade für gerade linien 1 bat man
kann dort viel besser formen ob bei
modenschauen oder in der werbung man
trägt macht ein trend der seit einigen
jahren ungebremst ist
gerade jüngere männer sind offener
geworden für typ veränderungen
sie tragen ihren bart mal voll und lang
dann wieder als drei tage bart mit
gepflegten konturen
kein wunder dass nun auch kostspieligere
war pflege zum thema wird der moderne
bier serviert natürlich auch die drinks
die männer am liebsten trinken
es ist ja auch sehr bequem seinen
vollbart zu tragen weil man nicht viel
tun muss dafür und das ist gut dass mal
jemand sich darum kümmert diese
kosmetiksalon in berlin hat seit gut
anderthalb jahren auch eine rundum
beiträge im programm
auf jeden fall eine form von wellness
behandlung für für männer die auf eine
sehr angenehme art und weise den man die
möglichkeit gibt seine männlichkeit zu
behalten und trotzdem wellness in
anspruch zu nehmen
pflegeprodukte wie barth shampoo bürste
und bartel sind wieder neu auf den markt
gekommen
sie gehören zur 70-minütigen kingsize
behandlung von nicole friedens barbier
der aus new york stammt rasiermesser
sind momentan so gefragt dass einige
hersteller zeitweise sogar
lieferengpässe hatten für diese art der
rasur braucht es viel übung deswegen
lassen viele lieber einen fachmann an
ihre kehle beim ersten mal sind sie noch
nervös doch beim zweiten mal schon nicht
mehr
wenn sie sehen wie ich ihren bart
behandler und sie ein schäume dann haben
sie in dem moment in dem ich die klinge
ansätze schon vertrauen zwischen 20 und
78 euro zahlt der kunde für das kosmetik
programm beim berliner war wir längst
lassen sich auch männer ihre
schönheitspflege etwas kosten
ich komme eigentlich einmal die woche
her für auf alle fälle so einen kleinen
ausschnitt oder ried rim und einmal im
monat so eine stunde mit kompletten
treatment und haare schneiden und alles
und es sind immer die highlights der
woche auch immer mehr deutsche frauen
schenken ihren männern zu besonderen
anlässen einen besuch beim vintage war
wir
schließlich profitieren sie ebenfalls
von einem gepflegten bart